madame monsieur bonsoir voici les titres
que nous allons développer dans ce
journal le flot de réfugiés chassés du
kosovo par les forces serbes continuent
de déferler aux frontières de
l'allemagne et de la macédoine le
nettoyage ethnique se poursuit le temps
donne à ses troupes d'aider les réfugiés
les trois militaires américains fait
prisonnier mercredi devait passer devant
une cour martiale aujourd'hui
l'instruction est en cours
les mouches en amérique bill clinton
vient de déclarer qu'il ne laissera pas
l'idée le trousseau vos impunément
invités de ce journal le secrétaire
général de l'otan ravier sanaa est tout
à leur emma bonino commissaire européen
à l'aide humanitaire en direct de
bruxelles
le match de jacques chirac aux victimes
de la catastrophe du tunnel du mont
blanc le président de la république
demande que toutes les responsabilités
soient tirées ce long week-end
traditionnellement meurtrier sur les
routes appelle à la prudence pour les
automobilistes le gouvernement décide
que la sécurité routière sera la grande
cause nationale de l'an 2000 les
chiffres donnent le vertige ces
dernières 24 heures trente mille
personnes ont été chassées de christina
est sur le chemin de l'exode
encore et encore ces images du désarroi
de la peur et de la souffrance celle de
ces familles entières qui trouvent ça
lui en albanie d'interminables files
d'attentes aux postes frontières ou nord
précisément de l'albanie dans cette
région la plus pauvre du plus pauvre
pays d'europe
nos envoyés spéciaux venait du kent dj
da quelque part sur la frontière
albanaise du côté de khroma les soldats
serbes sont bien visibles apparemment
indifférents aux missiles tomahawk qu'on
distingue à peine dans le ciel
toute la frontière et miner ce sont eux
qui guide les colonnes de réfugiés sur
les sentiers qui les guide
ou plutôt les escortes la balade n'est
pas voulu et l'exode et forcé tous les
moyens sont bons à milosevic pour
s'assurer que les albanais qui est
effectivement le kosovo 2500 personnes
sont passées ici en 24 heures
un chiffre dérisoire par rapport à ce
qu'on voit ici au poste frontière de
morina en six jours ils sont 140 milles
à l'avoir franchi un flot continu sans
cesse croissants et toujours rien ou
presque pour les accueillir
en fin de matinée cette équipe de
médecins du monde l'urgence est évidente
des moyens dérisoires et l'émotion
palpable on est 4 mai car pour attendre
des milliers de personnes qui passent en
4 classes qu'on a comme médicament on
est quatre personnes comment ça se fait
que aussi peu de monde aussi lieu où les
gens n'ont pas le temps peut-être ou
alors qu'ils sont en train de se reposer
dans des hôtels ou alors en meeting ils
n'ont rien d'autre à faire alors il faut
des meetings pour dans un mois quand
nous on n'aura plus rien à manger que
tout le monde sera mort de froid et
n'aura rien à voir il n'y a pas d'eau
y'a rien à manger sont restés pendant
des jours et des jours dans les bois y'a
rien à aucune condition d'hygiène ya
rien n'y a même pas de médicaments pour
ses pour malheureux
en ville ça n'est guère mieux toutes les
maisons les appartements sont occupées
par les réfugiés ou caisse ne peuvent
plus rien absorber il faut donc attendre
dehors et des médecins albanais de
l'hôpital tout proche ont ce qu'ils
peuvent avec les moyens du bord
transporter l'aide depuis tirana c'est
un vrai cauchemar
aux côtés des routes et infrastructures
qu'il ya ici les routes sont
complètement combret par les gens qui
arrivent avec leurs tracteurs et qui
tentent de quitter la région
donc le transistor est vraiment
problématique et ça prend du temps alors
il faut partir mais comment jusqu'à
présent les moyens de transport mis en
place par les albanais pouvait emmener
8000 personnes par jour
mais le flou et trop important et les
bus ne suffisent plus on n'a rien à se
mettre sous la dent depuis trois jours
on est dehors trempés et transis 3 on
attend des bus il y en a pas et tout ça
après avoir marché six heures dans la
boue entre milosevic et des
organisations humanitaires entre celui
qui chasse les kosovars par la terreur
et ceux qui tentent de les accueillir
dans la précipitation
la course de vitesse est engagée nous
retrouvons en direct de caisse benoît
duquesne le cri de révolte de sept
jeunes médecins du monde dans votre
reportage devant une aide humanitaire
bien trop lente à prendre en charge des
réfugiés
oui tout à fait donc c'est effectivement
un cri de révolte qu'il faut prendre
comme tel ce qu'il faut bien comprendre
c'est que personne évidemment n'avait
envisagé cette attitude de milosevic et
l'importance de ce coup de râpe huget
qui arriverait ici la stratégie entre
guillemets de l'ua cher était de ne
laisser personne arrêtée ici s'arrêter
ici puisque les structures de la région
sont notoirement insuffisantes
ils comptent essentiellement sur les
familles d'accueil pour accueillir les
gens et puis sur une évacuation
progressive des gens qui arriverait
c'est ce qui s'est passé le hr à
financer d'ailleurs cette cette
évacuation et puis essayer d'acheter ici
sur place et bien ce dont avaient besoin
les gens mais cette stratégie bien sûr
compte tenu de l'ampleur du mouvement
n'est plus valable
le hr est pour l'instant déborder les
routes sont complètement à combrée c'est
vrai qu'il est très très difficile
c'est vrai qu'il est très difficile de
faire venir ici la nourriture et les
besoins nécessaires
c'est donc
très difficile à vivre c'est vrai qu
emma bonino ses rangs du club hier sur
le terrain pour se rendre compte de la
situation c'est vrai qu'elle a annoncé
12 millions de dollars dell c'est vrai
qu'elle a annoncé qu'un camp et nous
l'avons vu qu'un temps allait commencer
à s'installer ici pour trier accueillir
ces réfugiés mais on peut se demander
pourquoi tout cela met autant de temps
via nous demanderons tous à emma bonino
qui sont notre invité dans quelques
instants
le président du conseil italien massimo
d'alema se rendra dimanche en albanie
auprès des équipes humanitaires qui
installent des camps pour les réfugiés
en france trois transall ont décollé ce
matin de la base aérienne d'istres dans
les bouches-du-rhône dans leur sens et
transforme les médicaments pour enfants
des biberons des produits de première
nécessité à destination de skopje en
macédoine
d'autres appareils avaient déjà décollé
hier de cette même base à destination de
tirana en albanie en macédoine
maintenant l'accélération de l'exode de
ces milliers de kosovars qui tentent
d'entrer en macédoine
hier chiffre record 40000 personnes à la
frontière qui sortent parfois au refus
des autorités de les laisser entrer avec
à chaque fois la désespérance de ses
victimes
acheminés par trains entiers reportage
jérôme ni andry sera il retourne au
kosovo en guerre après avoir déversé en
macédoine
des milliers de réfugiés qui vont
s'ajouter à tous ceux qui attendent
depuis deux ou trois jours déjà
terminus où beaucoup arrivent sur des
civières
accueillis par la croix-rouge
macédonienne les bonnes volontés se
mobilisent pour faire face à la détresse
des mafieux il ya surtout des gentils
polis
terrorisé des enfants aux vêtements
dérobés
il s'installe dans la durée ils savent
qu'il faudra beaucoup de temps avant de
pouvoir sortir de ce champ qu'ils sont
indésirables dans cette macédoine qui ne
veut pas que les albanais deviennent
majoritaires ils doivent se faire
enregistrer un par un pour obtenir un
visa humanitaire de trois mois sans
perdre patience face à la police
macédonienne les enfants nous jouerons
plus avant longtemps dans les rues de
pristina
tous les habitants de christina son
parti tout le monde est là dans le train
il y avait tellement de monde que l'on
ne pouvait pas s'asseoir
si nous restons ici encore une journée
nous allons vivre comme des animaux ils
ont tout perdu même la dignité pour
laquelle ils se sont battus au kosovo
les frappes aériennes de l'otan depuis
neuf jours maintenant mettre de l'huile
sur le feu de la haine les serbes les
ont forcés à l'exil
les policiers ont tout pris tout casser
ils nous ont fait sortir dans la rue
arrivé ici on n'a rien à manger
on a peur des épidémies
si rien n'est fait nous sommes au début
d'un processus de libanisation de la
macédoine avec des camps de réfugiés
mais aussi des bases arrière
d'entraînement pour la guérilla
indépendantiste de lui ces cas qui va
continuer de se battre contre l'armée
serbe au kosovo nous retrouvons en
direct de bruxelles emma bonino vous
êtes commissaire européen à l'aide
humanitaire bonsoir vous étiez ces deux
derniers jours aux postes frontières où
se massent ces milliers de réfugiés dans
notre reportage au début du journal
d'une jeune médecin du monde arrive en
albanie crier sa révolte son impuissance
et c'est vrai qu'on a le sentiment que
l'aide humanitaire tarde à venir et
qu'au fond vous avait été pris de court
mais ça c'est absolument vrai d'autant
plus que ce n'est pas une exode
humanitaire comme nous le connaissons
c'est le résultat d'une campagne
délibérée de déportations forcées ou
c'est le président milosevic qui joue
quand comment et où envoyer les gens
donc d'abord l'albanie maintenant la
macédoine le monténégro complètement
déstabilisée et la dimension de l'astre
cité de la férocité les gens sont privés
de passeport ce qui fait aussi que la
régie stration après dramatique comme si
on voulait annuler toute possibilité de
retour leur dignité etc
mais c'est que la d'image oui à
continuer nous c'est que la dimension de
ce qui se passe de ses chine de liste
c'est la liste de schindler c'est la
répétition des déportations forcées
qu'on avait vus et on espérait jamais
plus revoir en europe dans des pays tout
à fait fragile dans des montagnes
inaccessible où c'est vraiment difficile
de bouger même des bus donc mais ce que
je veux dire moi c'est que pour ceux qui
sont arrivés après quelques jours de
chaos ce sera où ils vont plus risqué
leur vie
mais qu'est ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur le million de percevoir qui
sont encore à l'intérieur
prête à être déportée est-ce qu'on va
assister à tout ça ils sont sans
protection alors si vous voulez bien
comparer - sans rien du tout on va
revenir emma bonino sur cette tragique
questions mais d'abord très concrètement
venant à l'aide humanitaire
l'union européenne va débloquer 10
millions d'euros supplémentaires
mais toute façon comment faire face
concrètement à cette catastrophe
humanitaire qui est et si prévisible et
que l'on voit jour après jour
et finalement on a l'impression que les
choses avancent très peu et très mal je
suis désolé que ce soit prévisible on
peut bien le dire d'un bureau de paris
plutôt que de londres 1 s'était pas
prévisible j'espère une campagne de
déportation forcée parce que si
quelqu'un ne savait devait bien
l'empêcher avant et je pense que ce
qu'on est en train on a besoin dans
cette complexité de logistique qui
seulement les militaires en fonctions
civiles peuvent donner ce n'est plus une
dimension qui puissent être réglés et
aborder avec les purs moyens
humanitaires
il faut pas beaucoup plus que ça parce
que ça a dépassé toute prévision
impossible donc ça on le voit bien et on
le comprend bien d'après ce que vous
nous dites et les reportages le manque
le secrétaire général de l'otan que nous
avons interviewé en fin d'après midi
nous confirme que les troupes basées en
macédoine viendront en aide aux réfugiés
c'est donc une bonne chose c'est dans le
bon sens et ce que vous voulez oui
absolument
et en plus il me reste la préoccupation
horrible pour ce qui se passe à
l'intérieur 80 % de la population qui
arrivent sont des femmes des vieillards
et des enfants où sont les hommes à mal
et chez vous ils ont été séparés par la
force
quel destin pour saison est-ce qu'on va
découvrir dans quelque peu de temps des
fosses communes
voilà ce qui est le double secteur d'une
drame d'une catastrophe tout à fait
organiser systématique voulu et depuis
dix ans dans cette dans cette partie du
monde
j'espère que les gens l'opinion publique
ne va pas oublier aux jets vukovar ce
brennus à la honte de sarajevo et bien
comprendre qui est l'agresseur est le
protagoniste de tout ce désastre
on vous entendra je l'espère vous
réclamez ce soir une protection armée au
seul pour l'aide que vous c'est à dire
je dis simplement que ce soit
et moi comme commissaire humanitaire je
dois aussi me préoccuper de ces gens là
qui sont sans protection et que
l'application de la convention de genève
est tout à fait violer si on décide
d'assister à la déportation c'était un
choix
moi j'ai pas le droit à l'indifférence
les conventions de genève ne me le
permettent pas vous pensez vous sera
entendu par la communauté internationale
je vais déjà essayer a commencé à
contacter les différentes capitales
j'espère qu'on va pas répéter une fois
de plus la honte de sarajevo
merci ma bénigne ou de cette interview
difficile les mots sont parfois
insuffisants pour décrire la situation
d'extrême précarité de ces milliers de
réfugiés qui arrivent sans interruption
en albanie aujourd'hui on parle
d'urgence humanitaire majeure les
capacités d'accueil
malgré la solidarité sans faille des
albanais ne sont que provisoires est
aujourd'hui difficile de faire face à
tirana bertrand cocq roger meute dans
les plis du fleuve fanni c'est un petit
coin d'albanie à 100 km au nord de
tirana cubique 4000 habitants longtemps
cubique avec lui de lusine de cuivre les
193 usine a fermé et peu à peu la ville
c'est un
depuis cinq jours maintenant public voit
passer les réfugiés
surtout des femmes et des enfants les
visages chiffonné entre de sommeil les
regards où s'accrochent la peur comme
une maladie le chauffeur est d'ici il
dit que le gouvernement paye les sens
que lui fait ça pour rien encore un
instant et les voilà partis vers tirana
mais plus loin
d'autres sont restés et dans cette
région catholique l'église a pris sous
sa protection ces kosovars mahométans
sander et secrétaire de mairie il à
charge d'âmes
en plus de ses 4000 administrés 150
réfugiés donner toute la famille il est
laid il a été à l'hôpital et il ne s'est
pas sa famille le vieux ramadan est seul
à gimat toute sa famille sa mère sa
femme et ses six enfants sa famille
trois frères sont restés au kosovo il
dit qu'il veut rentrer chez lui mais il
ne sait pas quand sa dernière riz du
rire des anges
elle a cinq mois et la villa tient en
réserve
sander organise la pénurie il a
l'habitude
la mairie de cubic fournit déjà
l'ordinaire de presque toute la ville
150 bouches de plus à nourrir sander
branche pouvoir tenir deux mois à
condition d'être aidé nous avons besoin
d'être à nous avons déjà un délit
nous avons besoin j'étais la cuisine
nous avons besoin aussi t&d chose d
autre chose à manger
le gouvernement albanais peut vous aider
vous croyez où il en est incapable
le gouvernement albanais dans ces
moments de la ville trois jeunes filles
ont apporté des oeufs du lait du pain et
du chocolat dans son français l'écolier
le petit secrétaire de mairie dit ce
sont les citoyennes il en effet ceux qui
vivent de peu savent que tout se partage
venons en maintenant au sort des trois
prisonniers américains dont il était dit
depuis hier qu'il passerait en cour
martiale dans la journée ce que l'on
peut dire à peu près à coup sûr ce soir
c'est que l'instruction de ces giles est
encore richard dean et en diffusant les
images des visages tuméfiés des trois
soldats américains
slobodan milosevic c'est qu'il viole
ouvertement la convention de genève
les prisonniers de guerre doivent être
protégés en tout temps contre tout acte
de violence ou d'intimidation contre les
insultes et la curiosité publique
mais le maître de belgrade oppose sa
propre logique et gi's aurait selon lui
pénétrer clandestinement au kosovo il
n'y a pas eu de déclaration de guerre de
la part de l'otan justement ce sont des
prisonniers de guerre
le statut est indubitable les textes
sont clairs il prévoit que tous les
membres des forces armées d'une partie à
un conflit sont des combattants et que
tous les combattants capturés sont des
prises les guerres au cas pas de doute
ce sont des prisonniers qui doivent être
soumis au statut prévu par la convention
genève qui protège de manière assez
claire très précise les droits des
prisonniers les trois soldats devraient
donc être jugés pour espionnage par un
tribunal militaire d'exception une mise
en scène savamment orchestré destiné à
faire monter les enchères pour les
serbes
ils ne sont plus des prisonniers de
guerre protéger mais des citoyens
américains propre à servir de monnaie
des changes à milosevic
c'est la volonté de
dire qu'ils se moquent finalement du
droit international et que dans cette
affaire il s'agit surtout d'une grande
opération de propagande vis-à-vis de
l'opinion publique les milosevic on sait
très bien un peu de souci du respect des
visions monde par plus celle des trois
prisonniers de guerre américains que
celle des malheureuses populations
civiles du kosovo dans la guerre
médiatique qui le pose aux forces de
l'otan
slobodan milosevic semble avoir à
nouveau frappé le premier
l'opinion américaine est inquiète trois
de ses boys sont en danger
il sera désormais plus difficile de
défendre une guerre aux contours de plus
en plus floues ou pour l'instant peu de
règles ont été respectées
sinon celle de la force aux états unis
on imagine donc l'émotion des familles
de ces soldats qui ont donc été fait
prisonnier mercredi des rubans jaunes
des drapeaux américains
des panneaux qui appellent à leur retour
ici ou là aux états unis
la mobilisation à los angeles ou encore
au texas là où vivent les familles de
ces trois hommes et par an l'un des
jeunes soldats ont tenu une conférence
de presse
la capture de soldats américains a été
fortement ressenti dans l'opinion
publique qui depuis plus de 36 heures
voit sur toutes les chaînes de
télévision l'image de ces soldats
prisonniers
l'occasion pour l'amérique de
s'interroger sur ce conflit en
yougoslavie
photo instantanée de ces new-yorkais
dominique derda s'étaler détails comme
celui ci une carte du monde épinglé sur
un mur que l'on devine que les ventes
buren n'appartiennent pas à cette
caricature que l'on retient parfois de
l'amérique un pays si vaste qu'ils en
ignorent souvent ce qui se passe au delà
de ses frontières alors des informations
toute la famille réunie
il zappe d'une chaîne allons le kosovo
ils n'ont pas attendu les premières
frappes de l'otan pour savoir où ça se
trouve
quand je pense à la façon dont les
russes dans les camps sans réagir quand
les grecs au risque que ce conflit ne
s'étende alors oui vraiment ça
m'inquiète
les bandes buren on l'aura compris ne
sont pas des va-t-en-guerre plutôt
dépassé rice
cette fois pourtant ils soutiennent même
si c'est à contre-coeur l'intervention
de l'alliance atlantique faire voir que
l'on utilise la force pour défendre une
cause humanitaire du moins c'est comme
ça qu'on nous présente les choses je
trouve que comme ce fut le cas lors de
la guerre du golfe ou en gros on
protéger nos intérêts économiques au bar
du village dans cette banlieue populaire
de new york les propos recueillis n'ont
certes pas valeur de sondage il résume
malgré tout est assez fidèlement ce que
ressent l'amérique alors que trois de
ses soldats sont aux mains d'un homme
dont ils ont encore du mal à retenir le
nom
je ne veux pas que nos troupes
celle de l'otan celle de nos alliés
aillent se faire tuer pour rien tout ça
à cause d'une seule personne dictateur
slobodan mijalkovic tous pourtant ne
partage pas cet avis loin de là moi j'ai
deux gosses ma fille à 13,1 mon fils
disant sont on voit pleurer ses enfants
de réfugiés si ça vous laisse insensible
alors c'est que votre coeur ne sont par
an on ne peut pas rester les bras
croisés
combien de temps encore allons nous
supporter ce terme de nettoyage ethnique
est ce que ce n'est pas un mot terrible
c'est l'expression la plus insupportable
qui soit pourquoi utiliser un tel
vocabulaire pour décrire ce qui n'est
d'autre que le meurtre le génocide à la
télévision les hommes politiques
républicains ou démocrates les experts
les conseillers malgré leurs divergences
sur la stratégie à employer ne disent
pas autre chose
les etats unis sont allés trop loin pour
faire marche arrière en direct de
washington philippe gassot comment donc
l'opinion américaine at elle évolué ces
dernières heures est elle en train de
prendre conscience peut être de faire
volte-face
écoutez le dernier élément que nous
ayons c'est à sondage cbs qui indique
que le soutien bill clinton n'a pas
véritablement évolué 53% des américains
le soutiennent 34 % d'entre eux
considèrent qu'ils n'ont pas grand chose
à faire au kosovo mais là où les
chiffres deviennent intéressant c'est
que 65% des américains considèrent que
tôt ou tard et malgré les dénégations de
bill clinton il y aura des troupes au
sol et 80% 84 % exactement des
américains considèrent qu'il y aura des
victimes
et là la grande majorité des américains
n'est pas du tout prête à payer le prix
du sang pour le kosovo alors vous le
voyez on revient un peu à la case départ
si l'on veut voir un jour rentrer les
réfugiés chez eux
il faudra bel et bien des troupes au sol
on peut préparer une guerre avec
l'aviation
on la gagne avec la fonderie merci
gayssot revenons à présent sur le
terrain des opérations militaires les
forces alliées continuent leurs
bombardements avec des cibles
diversifiée une forte explosion avait
retenti après stinat en fin de matinée
alors qu'auparavant les avions de
l'alliance aurait touché un site
militaire au sud de belgrade
dans l'ensemble les frappes sont moins
importantes que les nuits précédentes
prends-ça corner les mauvaises
conditions atmosphériques sur la serbie
le kosovo et le monténégro ont contrarié
effectivement la nuit dernière et ce
vendredi les opérations aériennes de
l'otan
de nombreux appareils sont restés cloués
au sol et bon nombre d'avions qui avait
décollé pour une nouvelle série de
frappes sont rentrés à leur base avec
leurs missiles accroché sous les ailes
car les consignes données aux pilotes
sont clairs ils doivent s'en tenir à des
bombardements précis et renoncer plutôt
que de faire prendre des risques aux
civils c'est donc à partir de ce navire
de guerre américain croisant avrillas
tic le yoyo à 16 philippines ont été
menées aux missiles tomahawk la plupart
des raids de la nuit dernière
ces missiles de croisière
s'affranchissant eu des conditions météo
sur leur trajectoire des sites
militaires des centres de commandement
et des casernements été touchés selon
l'otan mais si l'on en croit les
réfugiés fuyant le kosovo les casernes
et les commissariats sont vides
soldats et policiers s'est installé dans
les maisons des kosovars chassés de
leurs villages
slobodan milosevic a reçu aujourd'hui
une délégation de parlementaires russes
et biélorusses conduite par sergei bas
bourrine vice président de la douma le
président yougoslave a profité de cette
visite pour demander cela pour la
première fois publiquement aujourd'hui
une aide militaire à la russie afin de
défendre plus facilement la yougoslavie
je cite contre les attaques de l'otan
interrogé à moscou le kremlin a éludé la
question en soulignant que ces
parlementaires qui se sont rendus sur
les lieux des bombardements comme ici à
cacak n'avait aucun mandat et n'était
envoyé ni par le président ni par le
gouvernement russe en serbie
les soutiens slobodan milosevic se
multiplient par ces démonstrations de la
population dans tout le pays à novi sad
au nord ouest de belgrade où la
destruction hier matin de ce pont
enjambant le danube a été filmé par la
caméra infrarouge du chasseurs
bombardiers de l'otan qui a mené ce raid
les habitants sont eux aussi descendus
dans la rue pour démontrer que ce
bombardement n'affectait en rien leur
détermination de rester derrière leur
président le premier né vers navire de
guerre russe a appareillé ce matin pour
se rendre dans l'adriatique près des
côtes des slaves
il devrait être suivi par d'autres
bateaux qui pourraient gagner
prochainement la région du conflit
gilles rabin france brécey ouverture
médiatique très contrôlé une seule
caméra autorisé pour l'appareillage du
liman le navire espion que l'état major
russe a décidé d'envoyer au large les
yougoslaves vieux bateau datant de plus
de 25 ans camouflé en navire
océanographique
c'était la règle à l'époque soviétique
sur lequel il n'y a presque plus
d'officiers que deux matelots leur
métier c'est le renseignement militaire
les navires qui doivent le rejoindre
pour assurer le train dé ce cadre c'est
à dire le ravitaillement et la
protection en mer sont aussi vieux entre
24 et 30 50 services dernière
bénédiction
sous le ciel gris de sébastopol dernier
alignement de sortie de port le liman
n'a pas pris la mer depuis un an
cap sur le détroit des dardanelles le
bosphore et l'adriatique navire espion
pour espionner l'otan bien sûr mais pour
le compte de qui d'après commerçants pl
quotidien le plus anti communiste de
russie
les services de renseignement russes
informerait les serbes sur les avions de
l'otan
leur itinéraire leur nombre et le type
d'appareil vrai ou faux scoop la radio
la mieux informée echo de moscou l'a
repris à l'antenne mais avec des
réserves
elle a sorti une autre information
sensationnelle des fragments de l'avion
furtif américain steve f-117 abattu en
yougoslavie la semaine dernière ont été
rapportés en russie les yeux base avons
donné à la russie aux militaires russes
l'avion stern ou les parties de l'avion
16 en échange de quoi la france c'est la
seule aide que la russie puisse apporter
aujourd'hui à la yougoslavie puisqu'il
n'est toujours pas question de rompre
l'embargo sur les armes
le navire espion russe qui est parti ce
matin
participera-t-il seulement à cette
guerre de l'information ou aussi malgré
son grand âge à la guerre tout court
en fin d'après midi nous avons pu nous
entretenir en direct de bruxelles avec
le secrétaire général de l'otan ravi et
cela n'a ma première question concerne l
utilisation des forces de l'otan bge en
macédoine pour aider les réfugiés ont
pris la décision d'aider des maîtres et
où les forces qui sont déployés à
macédoine pourrait aider bien entendu
les possibilités que nous avons d'avenir
1 entre sourds d'aider à sécuriser tous
les réfugiés qui sont là et pour aider
aussi à un gouvernement dit macédoine
pourrait maîtriser les problèmes au plan
militaire
je dirais que vos objectifs sont plus en
plus nombreux et de plus en plus
diversifiée en étant précisément à ce
dixième jour de bombardement quelques
mots je crois que quelqu'un tous les
efforts que nous sommes en train de
faire que nous continuons à faire et
vont diriger de manière très claire à
affaiblir les infrastructures militaires
la capacité militaire des pays
d'amérique et on va réussir si nous
continuons avec détermination dans les
câbles que nous savons la décision vous
en prie les derniers jours l'armée serbe
ne résiste mieux que prévu et il faudra
plus de temps que prévu
certes là mais très très fort vous le
savez bien l'été dans l'histoire est une
arme maîtresse important en europe mais
on va continuer notre effort pour
affaiblir cette armée en particulier la
machine de guerre la composante de cette
armée qui est engagée dans la violence
et la le nettoyage ethnique en
consommant il semble que cette nuit a
fait la nuit dernière en tout cas
beaucoup de vos appareils sont rentrés
avec leurs bombes intacte pour quelle
raison ce sont des raisons d'aidé dépend
délai les la médium et malheureusement a
été mauvaise pour les pour les avions
des intérêts et nous ne voulons pas
risquer de faire des dommages
collatéraux et donc les avions retour
s'il y a pas dit s'il ya des problèmes
avec la météo
alors quelques questions directes est si
rapide que dire ce soir de la situation
monténégro on sait que plusieurs
généraux ont été licenciés est ce que la
situation est très mouvante très
préoccupante
je suis très très préoccupés sur la
situation au monténégro parce que c'est
vrai que les changements des
commandements de l'armée cernent au
monténégro qui décision qui a été prise
hier par me lasser vite c est mauvaise
et et des nouvelle parce que
probablement ça veut dire que la
personne qui va prendre la
responsabilité de l'armée sur monténégro
sera un personne plus proche des 1000
assez vite
ça veut dire que probablement il voudra
faire quelque chose des mauvaises on
obtenait vend aussi
alors messieurs milosevic ce soir a
demandé l'aide militaire de la russie
pour vous il s'agit de
gesticulations je crois que la la la
russie va continuer comme est des points
de vie et stratégique de la même
longueur d'ondés que les pays de l'otan
parce que nous voulons les mêmes les
mêmes objectifs j'ai trouvé une solution
diplomatique pacifique à la question du
kosovo mais c'est vrai que nous sommes
écartés à ce moment si la question de
l'activité de l'otan et je crois que la
russie etc comportera de manière
responsable
parce que les problèmes de bruits graf
et nous voudrons de continuer après la
mecque coopération que nous avons
obtenus avant avec la russie 6e en avez
vous eu des contacts directs vous les
pays de l'alliance avec monsieur rugosa
part des tout à ces moments je voudrais
avoir des contacts avec monsieur roux va
diluer d'hyères qui après l'entretien
qu'il a qu'il a fini avec milosevic
quillet voudrait voir et messieurs vous
revoir ici à bruxelles à paris pour les
bruits voir de manière personnelle et
constaté la santé qu'il a à ce moment et
si les nombreux livres
au contraire il l'est pas merci monsieur
scène et d'avoir répondu à nos questions
et à propos d'ibrahim rugova est en
effet la communauté internationale
continue de s'interroger sur les
déclarations du chef modérée des
albanais du kosovo ou lendemain de sa
rencontre avec slobodan milosevic
pour l'instant nous ne disposons que de
la version officielle du go slave et
personne n'a réussi à avoir des
nouvelles de la famille d'ibrahim rugova
la france à travers un communiqué du
quai d'orsay indique qu'il serait le
bienvenu dans notre pays
eric monnet
c'est à la télévision serbe que l'on
doit ces images la rencontre entre
milosevic et rugova hier reprises par
les chaînes du monde entier reprises et
même analysé aujourd'hui dans
l'événement sent la manipulation
comment le leader modéré des albanais du
kosovo at il pu sinon sous la contrainte
a posé sa signature à côté de celles de
milosevic
alors que les suspicions de nettoyage
ethnique n'ont jamais été aussi forte
la veille déjà à pristina il était
réapparu après plusieurs jours de
silence pour réclamer un arrêt des
bombardements
on sait l'homme profondément non violent
mais c'est bien le même ibrahim rugova
qui réclamait lundi dernier encore dans
une interview à der spiegel
une action tereos de l'autre alors
pourquoi ce revirement
les forces alliées disent douter de sa
liberté de mouvement
c'est aussi l'avis de ses soutiens à
park n'a dû lui faire subir un chantage
c'est ma théorique
pendant quatre jours on nous l'a caché
et je savais qu'on nous le rendrait au
moment où ils vont si on nous le rende
est vivant c'est qu'il avait accepté de
signer quelque chose si on nous le rende
est mort c'est qu'il avait refusé de
signer quelque chose alors l'écart entre
les deux est très minces parce que je
dirais que rogova à l'heure actuelle de
toute façon et c'est terrible à dire
c'est un mort vivant alors ibrahim
rugova prisonniers soumis au chantage de
milosevic l'armée de libération du
kosovo adversaires politiques de rgo va
veut bien le croire aussi
mais n'exclut rien cependant s'il n'a
pas été forcée alors il a commis un acte
de haute trahison envers son peuple à
tirana le président albanais mais dany
lui va jusqu'à douter de l'authenticité
même de la rencontre sans aller jusque
là pour les occidentaux
seul un contact direct avec le leader
kosovar pour élever ce qui est ce soir
bien plus qu'un doux
je vous propose à présent l'itinéraire
de ces serbes qui ont quitté la france
mardi soir pour regagner belgrade
une de nos équipes étaient à bord de ce
quart qui a franchi la frontière
yougoslave
arnaud ardoin christophe airaud les uns
partent les autres restent mais surtout
les visages la même gravité
c'était mardi dernier boulevard richard
lenoir à paris à la grâce de dieu
tous sont serbes et vista paris depuis
dix ou vingt ans tous vont retrouver
là-bas au terme d'un voyage de 2500
kilomètres leur famille et leur patrie
elle est retraitée des usines citroën
lui est ouvrier toute une vie de travail
pour aider ceux qui sont restés là bas à
vivre un peu mieux avoir sans doute des
heures de route à imaginer ce qu'ils
vont trouver tandis qu'à la radio se
succèdent les mauvaises nouvelles
brad shaw le chauffeur vite à paris avec
son épouse ses enfants visite à belgrade
et chaque semaine il fait l'aller retour
pour une fois à chaque arrêt c'est
l'occasion de discuter de tenter de nous
convaincre du bien fondé de la cause
serbe
il est tout en un an il vous reste amis
ils vont se battre jusqu'à ce dernier
fait ça même les gens comme ils vivent
en allemagne où partout et il va venir
défendre son pays
dernière escale avant la frontière entre
la hongrie et la yougoslavie
ce soir ils n'arriveront pas les mains
vides là bas les produits de première
nécessité commencent à manquer
la frontière enfin pour eux la joie du
retour pour nous la possibilité de
filmer sans être aussitôt inquiétée par
la police serbe de longs détours pour
rejoindre belgrade les autoroutes sont
fermées par crainte des bombardements
après trente heures de voyage des
retrouvailles publiques
ma fidèle ici déjà on s'est installé
dans l'état de guerre
le lendemain matin avec prudence par
crainte des représailles policières
ratko nous ouvre la cave où dorment ses
petits enfants aussi mais rapidement il
est il est il est toujours difficile
dans la cave
parce que toulouse louis sénat coquilles
hakim qui n'est bon malgré tout les
nuits c'est le moment des confidences en
nous ouvrant sa porte rothko avait un
message à nous transmettre à nous
citoyens d'un pays membre de l'otan
s'est pas aux questions du public
même si il a dit oui le pop maintenant
parce que tous les jeunes il est tous
les peuples
il savait c'est mes propres histoires et
c'était amérique qui veut séparer au
kosovo et puis au delà des discours
politiques il y a surtout l'angoissé
d'un homme inquiet tout simplement pour
la sécurité des siens voici donc ce que
l'on pouvait dire ce soir sur la
situation us la vie à l'étranger encore
cette information washington confirme
des frappes aériennes dans le sud de
l'irak dans l'actualité le match du
président de la république aux victimes
de la catastrophe du mont blanc à
chamonix
jacques chirac y apporter son soutien
son amitié à la population de cette
station sans éprouver depuis le début de
l'année jacques chirac y ensuite tenu
une conférence de presse demandant que
toutes les responsabilités du drame
soient mises à jour nous l'écoutons une
enquête déterminera
toutes les causes que ce soit des causes
techniques ou humaines des terminales
cas échéant des responsabilités et à
partir de là toutes les conséquences
devons en être tirées tant en ce qui
concerne les problèmes techniques
naturellement que le cas échéant les
responsabilités humaines
la visite du chef de l'état n'aura pas
réussi à calmer les esprits aujourd'hui
la polémique s'étoffe un peu plus cette
fois ci s'oppose le maire de chamonix à
la société gestionnaire du tunnel du
mont-blanc virginie fichiers gilles
perret autour du drame le recueillement
n'a pas fait taire la polémique
aujourd'hui c'est au tour du maire de
chamonix d'accuser michel charlene n'a
jamais pu obtenir le moindre franc de la
tmb société gestionnaire du tunnel pour
l'aider à financer des moyens de secours
spécifiquement adaptés aux besoins du
tunnel du mont blanc
ça fait dix ans qu'on demande aussi aux
différents présidents des cités du
tunnel d'aider la commune de chamonix a
payé l'épreuve les secours ça fait dix
ans qu'on nous répète c'est pas marqué
laquelle il cherchait la sphère des
collectivités locales ça s'est fait à
maintes reprises et dernièrement quand
nous avions proposé l'année dernière le
projet de nouvelle caserne qui est
aujourd'hui en cours la tmp n'a jamais
répondu à nos demandes
à l'époque l'actuel président de la tnb
rémy chardon avait répondu plutôt
sèchement que cela ne le concernait pas
ce matin devant nos caméras ils
n'étaient guère plus loquace
vous aurez un communiqué tout à fait
excellent très important ce qui disent
ça vous touche directement ce serait
bien d'avoir un communiqué va être
diffusé les seules réactions de la
société aujourd'hui se feront donc par
communiqués interposés au sujet du
casernement la tmb précise qu'elle
n'était pas compétente pour la
construction
cette charge incombe aux départements
quant à l'organisation globale des
conditions d'intervention dans le tunnel
le service départemental d'incendié et
de secours vise lui non seulement la tnb
mais aussi l'état pour en faire un
problème général a en france des
concessions de service public des ponts
des tunnels et des autoroutes qui me
semble t'il avec un ticket de péage
devrait pouvoir comme elles le font dans
d'autres domaines pouvoir subvenir aux
secours et qui doit organiser les
pouvoirs de police dans un tunnel
internationale ça dépasse largement vous
comprenez bien ma modeste le compétences
petites phrases assassines qui ne semble
pas atteindre pierre breuil
le préfet de haute savoie n'envisage pas
de démissionner pour l'instant et attend
sereinement les premiers résultats de
l'enquêté communiqués le 9 avril
prochain au centre de cette nouvelle
polémique la société d'exploitation du
tunnel du mont blanc une société d'état
qui est tiré de nombreux bénéfices
depuis l'entrée en vigueur du tunnel du
mont blanc le fonctionnement de cette
cécité pas comme les autres jean bernard
schmidt philippe turpault derrière cette
façade discrète
l'une des affaires les plus juteuses de
la république et l'un des fauteuils les
plus convoité celui de président de la
société des autoroutes et tunnel du mont
blanc
nous avons traversé le mont blanc depuis
1965 année de l'inauguration par le
général de gaulle onze personnalités ont
présidé la société parmi les plus connus
le père de valéry giscard d'estaing ou
encore edouard balladur qui restent à 13
ans de 68 à 81
il continua d'ailleurs à en tirer
quelques avantages jusqu'en 1988
bénéficiant notamment de trois
appartements dans un immeuble de
chamonix une charge donc très recherché
est attribuée par le gouvernement l'état
détient en effet 54% de la société du
tunnel autres actionnaires
les départements de haute
à voix et de l'un des banques et
compagnies d'assurance suisses et
françaises ainsi que la caisse des
dépôts le personnel contre lui un peu
plus de 1% des pas tout le monde est
très content car depuis sa création le
tunnel rapporte gros
l'an dernier la société a réalisé un
chiffre d'affaires de 800 millions de
francs pour un bénéfice net de 45
millions
les prix du péage sont eux toujours
aussi élevé 1500 francs l'aller retour
pour un camion 130 francs pour une
voiture à raison de 2 millions véhicules
par an la sphère n'a pas fini d'être
rentable au chapitre économique l'accord
sur les 35 heures chez renault
contrairement aux autres syndicats la
cgt a refusé de signer cet accord la cgt
qui s'était déjà ouvertement montré
hostile à ce projet la direction de la
ces et a bien confirmé aujourd'hui la
fermeture des sites de tonneins et de
morlaix lors d'une réunion
extraordinaire du comité central
aujourd'hui vendredi saint de nombreux
départs comme chaque année sur les
routes pour ce long week-end pascal
soyez donc prudents au volant ce matin
entre lens et strasbourg
un carambolage impliqué 35 voitures et
fait 18 blessés légers l'origine sont
dues à un rideau de fumée d'un incendie
d'un hangar agricole près de l'autoroute
à la veille donc de ce week-end
traditionnellement meurtrier sur les
routes le gouvernement a décidé
d'annoncer que la sécurité routière
serait la grande cause nationale de l'an
2000 jean claude gayssot le ministre des
transports a lancé un appel à la
prudence et à la responsabilité
voyons exemple du département du gard
vannes 3 tués depuis le début de l'année
il ya trois mois une association de
familles ayant perdu un proche sur les
routes a été mise en place
karine comazzi française oiseaux
guillaume karine et ghislain de ces
trois vies brisées dans la tôle au
détour d'une nationale les parents ont
gardé des clichés et de colère intacte
j'ai perdu mon fils est né le 24 juillet
mais il aime le chauffard ivre pour moi
quand on me dit comme ça c'est un
accident je dis non pour moi c'est un
meurtre six ans ferme pour le chauffard
qui a percuté guillaume le conducteur de
la voiture où karine est brûlée vive est
quant à lui en liberté il faut se battre
il faut pas laisser passer ça parce que
il a détruit une villa
une famille entière a été brisée moi
personnellement je suis morte sur more
time a fini le dégoût de la vitesse
excessive et de l'alcool au volant les a
réunis trois familles puis 50 qui disent
les mots qu'ils auraient voulu entendre
et retrouve un sens à leur vie
donc nous avons décidé de nous battre
pour les autres et en même temps pour la
mémoire de nos enfants pour dire ils ne
sont pas morts pour rien parce que ça
c'est la chose qui veut dire pour dire
si on peut arriver à sauver ne serait-ce
qu'une seule vie déjà c'est une réussite
outre le soutien moral et les actions de
prévention
l'association apporte une aide juridique
aux familles sport vélo mais on a eu
deux mois alcootest non pratiquer
erreurs dans les procès verbaux
chaque dossier des corail est presque
dans la ferveur chaque sursis et
contester sans désir de revanche du thon
simplement pour la justice ou
aujourd'hui en france on a la volonté de
faire en sorte se dit que ce qui est une
hécatombe s'arrête où on l'a pas si on
l'a pas les victimes de ce terreau ou
peu déçus par les mesures annoncées
aujourd'hui les familles sont parties
coller des affiches de l'association
guillaume karine ghislain trois noms en
guise de prévention
selon randy st avec plusieurs milliers
de fidèles qui ont accompagné le chemin
de croix de monseigneur lustiger à
montmartre qui a appelé à prier pour les
victimes de toutes les guerres et pour
la paix dans les balkans
et puis traditionnel le défilé autour de
l'église saint pierre de chaillot dans
le 16e arrondissement de paris
au total il y avait six chemins de croix
aujourd'hui dans la capitale
en espagne dans un pays marqué par la
piété et la ferveur le vendredi saint
est le plus gros pèlerinage de l'année
depuis le début de la semaine une
soixantaine de procession avec comme
aboutissement à séville et celui de la
macarena marque mise en oeuvre alain
poirier
comme les derniers vestiges d'un autre
temps les femmes en eau les hommes à
leur pied portant la vierge marie
ici à séville son nom c'est la macarena
la macarena est une confrérie uniquement
composé d'hommes dévoués comme ils
disent à la vierge
ils sont initiés par d'autres frères
officiellement il n'y a qu'une condition
d'entrée à respecter la foi la foi en
dieu la foi en la vierge pour moi la foi
en la macarena
ma foi et total définitive
les mêmes mots inlassablement répété une
litanie laissant peu de place au doute
dans la procession de la mclaren à une
ville entière est en adoration
tout le monde vient regarder on assiste
ici vos transports de la fois
littéralement partie à minuit de
l'église les 2250 pénitents de la
macarena participé à la procession
pendant toute la nuit nous offrons un
autre visage de la fois en faisant
pénitence en souffrent dans l'humidité
puis la chaleur pour les autres pendant
13 heures et le lendemain matin la
souffrance des pénitents devient un
spectacle pour la foule car souffrir
volontairement s'est mérité une partie
du pardon de dieu pour les catholiques
ordinaire personnel a sévi cette
souffrance ça pique
la macarena les montrer à la foule
qu'une fois par an depuis 1595 en
espagne la ferveur religieuse est à la
mesure de l'événement unique
tennis avec en coupe davis la première
rencontre qui a opposé le français
jérôme golmard 25e mondial à richard
krajicek
le français n'a pas gagné christelle
bertrand pour l'instant c'est lui le roi
de l'arène richard krajicek vient de
donner le premier point à son équipe
pourtant jérôme golmard est passé tout
près de la victoire pendant deux sets le
français joue vite et juste rydzek 4e
joueur mondial est neutralisée en fond
de court et à la volée en une heure et
quart le procès même 6/3 6/4 mais un
soir comme ça un hollandais n'en fait
jamais un fromage le public fait
beaucoup de bruit et porte le géant
crouch sec jusqu'au gain du tie break du
troisième set à l'énergie
le hollandais revient dans le match est
presque aussi vite que ses services il
gagne la rencontre en cinq sets
creil tchèque signe son retour en coupe
des 10 tarifs victoire après trois ans
d'absence
jérôme golmard déçu c'est ce qui a fait
la différence est réglé quoi il voyait
mon jeu il
il a elle s'est battue jusqu'au bout
passant devant champion rydzek a su
profiter d'un moment de faiblesse du
français la hollande mène 1-0 pour
l'instant et puis il n'ya pas longtemps
cédric pioline a mis la france et les
pays bas à égalité en battant le
néerlandais peut la russe 6 2 7 6 7 0 6
3 un match qui a duré 2 heures et 2
minutes précisément
c'est la fin de ce journal je vous
rappelle les principaux titres le flot
de réfugiés chassés du kosovo par les
forces serbes continuent de déferler aux
frontières de l'allemagne et de la
macédoine le nettoyage ethnique se
poursuit les trois militaires d'amérique
a fait prisonnier mercredi devait passer
devant une cour martiale aujourd'hui
l'instruction est en cours l'émotion
d'amérique et bill clinton vient de
déclarer qu'il ne le sera pas viser le
kosovo impunément dans un instant la
météo nathalie rihouet puis le point
roots valérie maurice 20h55 pj votre
fiction policière
01 10 le dernier journal pense duprat je
vous retrouve demain dès 13h merci de
votre attention
excellente soirée sortant